[Música]
día complicado para los mercados para
wall street' los detalles y la
explicación de por qué ocurrió esto lo
tiene jorge hurtado aquí en el estudio
de france 24 los indicadores tenemos que
comenzar por ahí porque la jornada fue
muy complicada jorge santiago las
acciones estadounidenses cayeron en su
peor jornada en casi dos años esto luego
de que el minorista target informará de
una importante reducción de ingresos
durante el primer trimestre la empresa
declaró beneficios de mil millones de
dólares entre enero y marzo eso es la
mitad de lo que ganó en el mismo periodo
2000 21 la empresa lo atribuyó la
inflación y ala a los problemas en la
cadena de suministro aunque esta caída
empezó ayer con walmart que anunció que
sus ganancias habían caído en el primer
trimestre un 25 por ciento respecto al
mismo período del año anterior tanto
target como walmart anticipan una
reducción en el consumo por la inflación
más alta en cuatro décadas que vive eeuu
y bueno en wall street' quien se llevó
la peor parte fue el nasdaq el índice de
las empresas tecnológicas que hay un 4,7
por ciento en europa las acciones
también cayeron lideradas por los
valores tecnológicos sobre todo por la
preocupación de la inflación y el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
y en américa latina la bolsa la
colombiana y la de brasil tuvieron su
peor desempeño arrastrada por estos
factores externos jorge pero como
siempre hay alguien beneficiado o algo
beneficiado y en este caso es el dólar
que comienza a repuntar y toma fuerza a
nivel internacional y es que luego de
sufrir ayer casi su peor caída en dos
meses el dólar tomó terreno nuevamente
la demanda del billete verde ha subido
como consecuencia del aumento de los
tipos de interés en eeuu asimismo por
ser considerado un activo de refugio el
dólar ha subido un 6,3 por ciento desde
principios de este año y llevó al yen a
su nivel más bajo en dos décadas el euro
vuelve a estar casi a la par con la
moneda estadounidense por primera vez
desde el 2002 pero esta subida del dólar
golpea también a los países
desarrollados y emergentes como nuestros
países de américa latina hablemos ahora
de las naciones unidas- que presentó su
previsión de crecimiento mundial que
sean cifras positivas por favor
lamentablemente lo contrario rebajó la
previsión de crecimiento del 4% al 31 %
para la economía mundial este año como
consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania la
organización estima que las principales
economías del mundo serían afectadas por
este conflicto y progresarán por debajo
de lo esperado pronostican un 2,6 por
ciento en el caso de eeuu un 2,7 para la
unión europea y un 45 para china el
nuevo reporte señala que la economía de
ucrania caerá en 2022 o entre el 30 y el
50 por ciento como resultado de esta
guerra mientras que la rusa se contraerá
un 10,6 por ciento del organismo señal
entre los principales problemas el de la
inflación que predicen aumentará este
año 67 por ciento a nivel mundial más
del doble que la media que se había
mantenido entre 2010 y 2020 generando
también una importante subida de los
precios de los alimentos y la energía-
también revisaron a la baja a la
economía de américa latina y el caribe
aseguran que va a crecer la región 2,1
por ciento bueno paciencia con esa
recuperación económica vamos a chile
aprobaron un histórico aumento salarial
allí en este país suramericano el
parlamento de ese país aprobó este
proyecto para elevar el salario mínimo
un 14,3 por ciento en 2022 el sueldo
mínimo pasa de los 350.000
actuales que son unos 411 dólares hasta
hasta unos 470 dólares este representa
el mayor ajuste en 25 años el aumento
resultado de un acuerdo entre el
ejecutivo y la central unitaria de
trabajadores que es la central sindical
más grande del país suramericano la ley
incluye un subsidio a las pymes para
cubrir el alza del salario mínimo que
esté por encima de la inflación la
inflación anual allí en marzo fue del 94
por ciento obligando al banco central a
subir la tasa de interés del 2,75 hasta
al 7% en menos de medio año 'jorge
cifras del día para el cierre el ex
ministro de exterior húngaro dijo que
para poder prescindir del petróleo ruso
su país necesitaría cuatro años y una
inversión de 750 millones de euros a
propósito de este paquete de sanciones
en los que se incluye el veto del
petróleo ruso gracias jorge por este
completo reporte de ustedes sigan por
favor en sintonía de france 24 a
continuación el debate